the battle between House Republicans in
the Justice Department over the Russia
probe is rapidly intensifying this
evening a group of republican
congressmen have filed articles of
impeachment against deputy AG rod
Rosenstein arguing that the DOJ has not
complied with nine months of oversight
requests for documents tied to the
investigation
joining us now exclusively to tell us
what's next Congressman Jim Jordan and
Mark meadows who are spearheading the
effort we're also joined by Fox News
anchor and author of the new fantastic
book big bestseller the Russia hoax greg
jarrett great to see all of you Congrats
Greg on the book great to have you on
Congressman meadows let's start with you
what are you accusing rod Rosen Stein of
specifically well really for nine months
we've asked for documents and and that's
all we want are the documents and what
we found is not only have subpoenas been
ignored but information has been hidden
the efforts have been stonewalled and I
guess for us is all about transparency
so the American people can judge for
themselves and so you know they may be
able to ignore Congress but they can't
ignore the American people this is what
Andy McCarthy wrote in National Review
he said Rosa Stein and Ray Chris Ray FBI
director worked for Trump they're not
Obama holdovers they're Trump appointees
if they're defined Congress it's because
the president is permitting them to do
so the president is empowered to give
his subordinates a direct order to
comply with congressional demands and to
fire them immediately if they fail to do
so he's kind of looking down on this
idea yeah
we've sent a letter to the president
mark myself and Congressman to say this
saying do you classify the information
get all and get us all the information
what have you ever spoken to him about
that I won't even to classify we sent
the letter several weeks ago but the
bottom line is we have sent numerous
letters to rod Rosa Stein they haven't
complied with two subpoenas they haven't
complied with we've caught the
Department of Justice hiding information
redacted information that they should
not have redacted we know that rod Rosa
Stein threatened House Committee Intel
staffers threatened them chilling impact
when they were trying to do their job
our job of getting doing the
constitutional oversight we're supposed
to do and we all know what the Justice
Department did with the dossier never
forget rod Rosa Stein signed the third
renewal signed that which was
which was based on the dossier which we
know came parts of it came from Bruce or
high rank official through his wife
Nellie the whole the whole ordeal so
we're tired of the Justice Department
giving us the finger and not giving us
the information we're entitled to do to
do our constitutional duty more
importantly the American people are sick
of it that's why we filed the resolution
just a moment I'm gonna ask you about
what House leadership including outgoing
House Speaker Paul Ryan is saying about
all this but Greg share it I want to go
to you Greg this is what happened on
Capitol Hill just recently when
congressman Jordan was trying to
question rod Rosenstein let's watch mr.
Rosen Stein why are you keeping
information from Congress
Carson I'm not keeping any information
from Congress that it's approved a few
minutes mr. Rosen Stein think the House
of Representatives going to say
something different I don't agree with
you congressman I don't believe that's
what they're going to say and if they do
then I disagree but I think we might
think no love lost between the
Republicans on Capitol Hill and in
Rosenstein Greg what's going on do you
think this idea of an impeachment vote
if they can get one is a good idea
absolutely Rosenstein has treated
Congress with nothing but contempt and
should be held in contempt and impeached
if appropriate this is a guy who has
been covering up from the very beginning
for nine long months the origins of the
Trump Russia hoax as I argue in my book
he and others never had any evidence of
collusion there was no evidence of
crimes or intelligence to justify a
counterintelligence probe Rosenstein is
the guy who put his signature on a
document to renew the wiretap warrant
application and he knew that that was a
fabricated phony document he didn't
present new evidence as the law demands
and he vouched for its authenticity when
he knew it was unverified and fabricated
and that is a fraud on the court and
abuse of power Mark Romero's it's been
hundred twenty two years since a member
of the executive branch has been impeach
for a long time that is a long time I
mean not not you know
obviously not talk about the president
but an executive branch employee other
than the president Paul Ryan doesn't
strike me as the kind of guy I was way
out long goodbye from Paul Ryan who
would be keen on this how do you get a
vote on impeachment without getting Paul
Ryan's nod here well certainly we hope
that it doesn't have to come to that
obviously this is the first step tonight
but it doesn't require consent from the
speaker
it's a privilege motion so what we put
in today was non-privileged it goes in
gets referred to the Judiciary Committee
but starting tomorrow we can bring it up
as a privilege motion what does that
mean yeah so and I'm glad you asked
because it really means that it would
require a vote on the House floor within
two days and that's something that any
member of Congress Jim or I can do and
and quite frankly it's either we hold
them in contempt or we get the documents
or we impeach him and and the only thing
that we have control over is the ability
to bring impeachment straight to the
floor
congressman Jordan any concern that this
will divide the GOP before the midterm
elections I mean the freedom caucus has
kind of a interesting relationships with
the with the most of Congress and it's
not a necessarily positive one at times
I mean all the issues but you know but a
lot of Republicans like oh my god the
freedom caucus every time they have
freedom caucus you lay this there yeah
we don't get that back home but yeah
doesn't divide the Republican voters
across this country doesn't divide so
you don't care who you offend on capital
you care about doing the right thing it
might have been 120 years since
someone's been impeached but when was
the last time you ever saw the FBI take
a disproven document with no credibility
no validity no corroboration take it to
a secret court not tell the court who
paid for it
not tell the court that the guy who
wrote it had been leaking information to
the press win of you and not just once
for stinking times and the last one rod
Rosa Stein's sign so if that's not
enough to force the action as Greg just
talked about contempt or impeachment you
tell me what is tell me what is because
I can't fear hey look we've been as
patient we started this a year ago in
July asking for documents we started
sending letters last week documents in
particular all of them we got a subpoena
with nine different things they're not
in compliance with three of that through
the elements in that subpoena issued by
Bob Goodlatte on March 22nd after we
first asked for them and letters are
their State Department documents that
you guys have wanted that you haven't
gone down we finally just for the last
few hours we have aa doubt about that
and so you know yes the thing is why do
we have to dig so deep to find out
information that should come
free-flowing if if we're really
interested in justice and Greg let's go
back to May when Rosenstein really got
us back up let's watch any reaction to
the news that certain members of the
house freedom caucus have talked about
drafting up articles of impeachment I
can tell you there were people who have
been making threats privately and
publicly against me for quite some time
and I think they should understand by
now the Department of Justice is not
going to be extorted extorted every time
I hear that I can't believe that's the
Deputy Attorney General jeff Sessions
bad choice in him yeah this is a very
vindictive man I was the first to report
actually that he threatened individuals
on the Intelligence Committee I reported
it in early February
how did I report it I talked to two
people who were in that meeting they
both felt that he was threatening them
to get his hands on their emails and
texts and telephone records if they
didn't back off this investigation
that's the kind of guy that rod
Rosenstein is he's presiding over an
investigation in which he is a key
witness and refuses to disqualify
himself even though it's mandatory you
can't be a prosecutor a witness and
investigator and the judge all ruled in
the one it's a violation of the
regulations and the code of Professional
Conduct for lawyers mark meadows before
we let you go what next for this you
know within two days you could have a
vote on this yeah literally hopefully
tonight there's a whole lot of
discussion going on I've had
conversations with the speaker's office
we're hopeful that we get some documents
that we
identified today but if not as soon as
tomorrow we could do a privileged motion
that would require a vote in two days I
think the American people are tired of
talk you know just like Jim was talking
about they want action and and it's it's
up to rod Rosen Stein Kevin McCarthy
with you on this I'm gonna talk to Kevin
let me talk to him all right guys some
people with this that's what matters
great to have you both on the Russia
hoax get this book gregg jarrett did a
fantastic job you want to understand a
very complicated story and a total scam
of waste of time for this country Reid
Greg's book Greg thanks so much